die ecotel de lausanne gehört zu den
renommiertesten handels schulen für die
hotelindustrie 2800 studenten aus über
110 nationen streben an der ehl nach
exzellenz können uns selbstbewusstsein
wir begleiten drei studenten im
vorbereitungsjahr und zwei am ende ihres
studiums
[Musik]
alexander schal er 18 jahre alt mit
seiner matura in der tasche geht er in
das vorbereitungsjahr immer bitte ist 21
sie wurde in der genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ein studium an dieser
internationalen schule genau wie alex
119 jahre alt der sohn eines hoteliers
geht mit selbstvertrauen ins erste
semester annina von falkenstein mit 21
beginnt sie ihre vorletzte studienjahr
die junge bärin strebt nach nichts
weniger als exzellenz achim becker 27
startet sein letztes semester der
energetische afri möchte selbstständiger
unternehmer werden
[Musik]
für immer ist es der große tag wie alle
die ihm vorbereitenden jahr mit der ehl
beginnen stellte sich darauf ein sechs
monate auf dem campus der schule zu
leben
bringst du gepäck für sechs monate mit
eigentlich kann ich jeweils am
wochenende nach hause erreichen bei
gedacht ich nehme einen kleinen vorrat
mit die anmeldung ist am ende des ganges
du wirst sehen die leute stehen nach
alphabete an
es gibt schalter für jeden namen
bekommst einen schlüssel und etwas
material dann holst du deine sachen und
wir suchen dein zimmer auf dem campus
perfekt vielen dank fast 400 neue
schüler kommen zweimal pro jahr und bei
jedem eintrittstermin ist die schule in
aufruhr nach langem suchen fand immer
ihren weg dieses mal ist sie sich ihrer
wahl sicher immer sie haben das zimmer
706 gebäude im zimmer befinden sich die
zimmer und die wäsche karte mit bereits
zehn franken guthaben sie können aufs
zimmer sobald sie wollen sie fragen
schüler vor der rezeption sie zu
begleiten und mit dem gepäck zu helfen
brauchst du hilfe
wir wissen nicht wo mein zimmer ist
du sprichst französisch nämlich an
also gehen wir ich begleite ich nehme
den koffer du wirst sehen du wirst viele
leute treffen die aus unterschiedlichen
welten kommen
du wirst oft schlange stehen aber es ist
angenehm auf dem campus gibt es gute
angebote
es hat küchen zur verfügung restaurant
bar es ist wirklich toll vor allem für
die neulinge auf dem campus
das ist aber groß ich habe es kleine
erwartet perfekt musst du davon
ehrlich gesagt ist es größer als
erwartet ich bin erleichtert ich hatte
ein wenig angst
es ist sympathisch und der fitnessraum
ist gleich unten das ist sehr praktisch
ein kleiner kühlschrank
das tagesprogramm verrät an der l ist
alles klar geregelt haben sie auch so
eine schule besucht überhaupt nicht ich
war zuerst krankenschwester und jetzt
bin ich psychologin in der
kinderpsychiatrie ich bin also gar nicht
in der welt des managements ich bin auch
im service aber im gesundheitsservice
die schule bedeutet ein wichtiges
finanzielles engagement
aber wir sehen es als geschenk an für
immer das ihr einen weg öffnet zu dem
wir einen großen anteil beitragen können
sie hat hart gearbeitet um auch selber
einen teil beizusteuern
das ist wirklich ein schönes geschenk
du hast freude daran und engagiert dich
wirklich sehr dafür was zählt ist die
motivation auch wenn man die mittel dazu
nicht hat emma ist sehr motiviert das
vorbereitungsjahr kostet fast 40000
franken
auch alex studiert das tagesprogramm er
hat sich für diese schule entschieden
nachdem er das von der ehl organisierte
sommer kennt besucht hat frühstück um 10
ligatore wir holen sein arbeitsmaterial
ein messerset seine schulbücher
so sind wir schneller denn du weisst du
bist ein bisschen im stress dort ist der
food court wo ich auch kochen werde
oben sind die klassenzimmer dort sind
die sushi bar und weitere
verpflegungsmöglichkeiten
nicht die schönsten schuhe aber
wenigstens sind sie komfortabel in den
ersten sechs monaten nehmen die schüler
an einer reihe von praktischen workshops
teil
insbesondere an dem fürs kochen für eine
parade wären sie unpassend aber hinter
dem herd sind sie obligatorisch
die passen perfekt gut für mich
logischerweise muss man alles ausziehen
denn wenn sie in der küche sind werden
sie nichts darunter tragen sie werden
das warm genug haben ohne t shirt und
jacke darunter sitzt wenn sie die arme
kreuzen soll das endlich zu eng seien an
den schultern hast die hose sie sind wie
sie sind da kann ich nicht viel ändern
hauptsache sie können sich gut darin
bewegen
marathon für die neuen anpassen der
uniformen für den service alle müssen
die kleiderordnung beachten
es sind studierende der hochschule für
gute ohren cia die die änderungen der
anzüge und der der damen kostüme
vornehmen
die von einer spezialfirma geliefert
worden sind sie können als erstes die
hose anprobieren mit der bluse drin und
danach schauen wir den rest an ok danke
schön
sieht gut aus können sie sich bewegen
perfekt komfort und eleganz stehen auf
dem programm
bei den frauen dürfen die ärmel der
bluse die des jackets nicht überragen
würden sie sich für die hose bitte kurz
umdrehen und mit den versen auf das
kleine stück holz stellen als ob sie
absätze hätten absatzhöhe 4 cm rose
einen zentimeter über dem boden
knielangen rock weder mehr noch weniger
mit seinen 19 jahren scheint alex on 30
wohl zu fühlen im anzug vielleicht weil
er an luxushotels gewöhnt ist sein vater
führt eines die ärmel länge
ich habe einen anzug und werde fünf
hemden und fünf weiße tierschützer
halten und eine hose
alle erhalten das gleiche die gleiche
uniform die gleiche krawatten farbe rot
alle haben die gleiche uniform im
service wie geht so gut und ihr ja danke
hast du deinen anzug schon geholt
naja ich hab gerade alles geholt hast du
die schule und die schürze ja ich habe
sie geholt und bin gerade daran sie zu
falten perfekt ich werde dasselbe machen
ich muss noch mal ein koffer auspacken
ich bin in hotels aufgewachsen
ich habe meinen vater arbeiten sehen
kennen das hotel business
es ist ein milieu das mich schon immer
fasziniert hat und das werk meines
vaters möchte ich fortführen
alexandra ist sprichwörtlich gern am
ball er spielt volleyball auf profi
niveau
ich kann es kaum erwarten in die saison
zu starten und zu sehen was sie mit sich
bringt hast du schon alles ausgepackt ja
alles ausgepackt mache ja auch gleich
noch
es ist ein team das normalerweise top
drei oder vier der schweiz wird ich bin
bereit diese herausforderung anzunehmen
bin sehr motiviert meine sportlichen und
beruflichen ziele zu verfolgen
es wird schwierig wir trainieren jeden
tag matches und turnier am wochenende im
oktober oder november gehen wir an die
europameisterschaft in rumänien
ich werde möglicherweise ein zwei tage
nicht hier sein können ein großes jahr
mit viel programm erwarte ich aber ich
bin bereit
vor zwei jahren war ich auf der
sportschule lausanne
dort gab es wirklich kleine petn ich
hatte angst dass diese betten auch klein
sein würden aber diese betten sind
gemütlich und breit
momentan verstehen wir uns gut die
beiden neuen krawatten dazu die wir von
der schule erhalten haben für
neuankömmlinge ist es manchmal nicht
selbstverständlich ein zimmer für sechs
monate mit einem studenten zu teilen
denn sie kaum kennen
aber das ist teil des campus lebens
so bleibst du zum ersten mal weit weg
von zu hause
ohne meinen bruder das ist sehr
beunruhigend aber mal sehen wie es wird
es ist aufregend aber auch ein wenig
unheimlich das gehört zum abenteuer
da wirst du lernen müssen sich zu
organisieren
er ist ein bisschen unordentlich
überhaupt nicht das wird hier nicht zu
sein
hier bin ich allein und werde selber
schauen müssen waren sie auch an zu
einer schule
nein ich war auf einer kunstschule ich
kann nichts anfangen mit dem ihr ich war
stylistin also überhaupt nicht im
gleichen bereich
ich hätte das ursprüngliche auch tun
sollen
programmänderung wir werden uns an die
umstände anpassen müssen
[Musik]
afrim 27 kam vor dreieinhalb jahren an
die ehl heute beginnt sein letztes
semester
ich weiß noch nicht ob ich froh bin
fertig zu sein oder traurig bin zu gehen
wir werden sie der food court hier essen
und arbeiten wir auch und treffen uns in
der gruppe er stärkt den zusammenhalt
und den teamgeist wenn man sich täglich
begegnet sobald man sich nicht darauf
zieht geht der teamgeist verloren und
man will dann schnellstmöglich wieder
hierher
ich bin sehr froh wieder zurück zu
kommen
heute hatte ich den ersten kurs in
unternehmertum
das war sehr interessant morgen habe ich
den zweiten kurs in innovation im
letzten semester ist es ein wenig
speziell denn wir haben drei die wir
frei wählen können sich besucher
unternehmertum innovation und einen
dritten kurs der mehr der hotellerie
entspricht der management mit optimaler
wirkung heißt ich hatte diesen kurs noch
nicht er wird eine woche dauern
jeden tag von 8 bis 18 uhr also sehr
intensiv und für die zwei anderen
workshops sind es zwei kurse pro woche
während vier wochen management
unternehmertum das vorbereitungsjahr und
die vielen workshops scheinen weit weg
für afrika aber er behält gute
erinnerungen an diese praktischen
ausbildung guten tag chef
wir machen einen kurzen rundgang in der
küche hier ist die warme küche alle
warmen speisen werden hier zubereitet
die kalten vorspeisen und gerichte dort
hinten und alles was beim cat ist wird
in einer anderen abteilung organisiert
hinten rechts stg küche dort ist die
bäckerei alles brot wird hier
hergestellt
hallo chef alles brot croissants und
süße backwaren werden direkt hier
hergestellt und an der schule verkauft
in diesem workshop verbringt man gerne
zeit
allerdings muss man dafür früh aufstehen
aber es ist sehr interessant
hier waren wir für eine woche food court
produktion hatten wir drei oder vier mal
während vier wochen die meisten
workshops dauern aber eine woche lang
das hier war mein lieblings workshop im
vorbereitungsjahr die wiege der sinne
so heißt das gourmetrestaurant der
schule ich weiß nicht ob sie schon die
möglichkeit hatten hier her zu kommen
das ist das spitzenrestaurant der schule
das 80 gäste empfangen kann
es ist wirklich genial man hat als
schüler die möglichkeit gourmetküche zu
degustieren und zu essen
mit der schüler karte kann man direkt
hier bezahlen
mit 20 prozent rabatt dann ist es nicht
mehr so teuer und wir haben das glück
die besten fachkräfte aus frankreich
hierzu haben die kochen und uns coachen
wir haben hier also die allerbesten
lehrer
[Musik]
annina 21 hat gerade ihr vorletztes
semester begonnen mit dem ehrgeiz zehn
von zehn exzellenz punkten zu erreichen
vielseitig engagiert übernimmt sie
zusätzlich zu den kursen verantwortung
beim buddy programm bei dem das patronat
über einen neuling übernommen wird
sie nutzt ihre mittagspause um areva zu
treffen
junior in deren partnerin sie ist bist
du jetzt im fünften bachelor semester ja
das ist mein letztes jahr
ich bin bald fertig aber es gibt noch
einiges zu erledigen
weißt du wurde dann später hin willst
ich habe gerade die human resources
entdeckt personaldienst das gefällt mir
würdest du gerne in die hotelbranche
einsteigen oder etwas völlig anderes
ich würde gerne in der hotellerie
bleiben wenigstens für ein paar jahre
wenn ich genug davon habt kann ich ja
etwas anderes machen und du das buddy
programm ist eine möglichkeit ihre
fähigkeiten in der betreuung und in der
hotellerie zu üben den beiden
leidenschaften der jungen baslerin ich
finde das system gut das netzwerk der
ehemaligen ist etwas wichtiges für die
schule schon im vorbereitungsjahr lernt
man die leute aus den höheren jahrgängen
und die bachelor studenten kennen
kennst du viele leute die an der hhl
sind ja während meiner zwei wochen im
boulevard in lausanne cafeteria
fingerfood sushi bar oder gourmet
restaurant um sich zu ernähren haben die
studenten die qual der wahl
alles eine frage des budgets ich bin in
der schweiz geboren und aufgewachsen
stamme aber ursprünglich aus dem kosovo
ich bin so'n von immigranten die 1988
hierhergezogen sie es gibt an dieser
schule nicht nur kinder aus wohlhabenden
verhältnissen die einfachen und
angenehmen leben meine eltern zb waren
politische flüchtlinge die nicht viel
mit brachten wir wohnten in einmal
schwierig bekannten quartier
sie mussten harte arbeiten und zeigten
mir wie man mit motivation etwas
erreichen kann
ich habe mich untypischerweise anstatt
fürs gymnasium für eine lehre
entschieden da ich aktiv sein und
schneller ins arbeitsleben eintauchen
wollte ich habe während vier jahren eine
lehre als mechaniker absolviert ich bin
mit 23 jahren hierher gekommen
ich habe das vorbereitungsjahr sechs
monate hier und sechs monate in thailand
absolviert das ist auch ein grund warum
ich die ehl machen wollte
so hatte ich die möglichkeit zu reisen
während der akademischen ausbildung
mein wunsch ist es ein restaurant zu
eröffnen wir versuchen gerade über den
ort zu verhandeln wir kennen das genaue
datum noch nicht aber die verhandlungen
laufen und wir werden bald einen
gesprächstermin fixieren
[Musik]
für immer und ihre kollegen geht es
weiter mit der begrüßungsrede des
direktors der hotelfachschule lausanne
weil die englische und die französische
sektion zusammen sind welt michelle
larissa die sprache von shakespeare
liebe neue studenten nicht sie haben die
ehl gewählt wir haben sie gilt als top
hospitality universität sind wir direkt
verbunden mit den besten firmen im
gastgewerbe liebe neue studenten das
studentenleben ist sehr anspruchsvoll
erlauben sie mir ihnen die drei
einfachen schlüssel zu geben die für
mich die basis des erfolgs dastehen
arbeit arbeit und arbeit danke und
willkommen in der familie
[Applaus]
die ehl familie ist die erste einheit in
einem viel größeren ganzen denn hier ist
vernetzung ein kern begriff
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da
[Musik]
dollar
endlich der aperitif wo die neuen und
ihre eltern einen vorgeschmack in sachen
exzellenz bekommen
[Musik]
der einst als kind mit
sie hat er sich für medizin
eingeschrieben dann wollte sie
kunstgeschichte studieren und plötzlich
bekam sie diese leidenschaft für das
event management und die hotellerie und
wir haben sie auf diesem weg begleitet
ich habe schon immer gesagt das
wichtigste ist es das zu machen was man
liebt sie hat er sich ausgesucht ich
vertraue ihr
ich denke es ist eine tolle wahl es ist
ein bisschen eine wir sind die besten
stelle ich glaube aber dass meine
tochter kritisch und klarsicht ich
bleiben wird über dieses wir sind die
besten
auf wiedersehen eltern hallo miss europe
das auge der ehl der große wächter über
die kleiderordnung und das gute benehmen
ich kenne sie nicht
aber wenn ich ihre gesichter sehe ihre
haltung ihr lächeln
die art wie sie sich anziehen und sich
anschauen dann habe ich eine recht gute
einschätzung ihrer mentalen einstellung
die kleiderordnung besagt nicht dass
jeder dunkelblau oder schwarz tragen
sollen
wenn ich sie anschaue sind sie fast alle
in einer uniform aber wenn sie so weit
gehen wollen geht das nicht zuerst
entfalten sie die krawatte komplett
bitte nicht so aufhängen so bricht die
saite
die idee ist sie aufzurollen und sie
flach zu halten und bitte niemand in
diesem raum zieht sie so an und aus ohne
den knoten zu lösen
nein jeden abend lösen und morgens einen
neuen knoten machen
sie gehen in die partie die bäckerei zum
housekeeping und es muss perfekt sein
willkommen in der welt des hügels für
einige von ihnen diese frage stellen sie
sich jeden morgen stimmt heute meine
professionelle erscheinung überein mit
den werten der ehl
ich werde sie nicht anschreien und ins
zimmer zurückschicken
nein wir machen das sehr professionell
sie erhalten von mir eine kleine karte
heute stimmt ihr professioneller
auftritt nicht überein mit den werten
der ehl
sie erhalten diese karte das ist nur der
anfang denn wenn ich ihnen diese karte
gebe bitte ich sie ihren ehl batch
auszuhändigen
wenn sie diesen auf dem campus nicht bei
sich tragen sind sie tot
sie können sich nicht bewegen nicht
essen nicht drucken sie können nichts
mehr tun
unter bush ist in meiner tasche
wenn sie den dresscode nicht einhalt
nehme ich ihnen den patch weg und gebe
ihnen zwei stunden um sich umzuziehen
auf dem campus werden sie beobachtet
viele leute beobachten sie die ganze
zeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie wollen dass jeder er selbst ist ein
original ist und trotz des dresscodes
seinen eigenen stil behält scheint aber
sehr paradox da wir alle dasselbe tragen
wir werden sehen wie sich das ganze ab
spielt momentan stört es mich noch nicht
wie ich bin und ein wenig lockerheit in
meiner kleidung schadet sicher nicht das
einzige was sich behalten kann sind
meine haare
also warum nicht davon profitieren aber
wenn mir dann gesagt wird dass mein
namensschild schief hängt dann finde ich
das einfach übertrieben
das ist der klassische krawattenknoten
der uns empfohlen wurde
und denen wir das ganze jahr so machen
letztes jahr als ich auf dem campus war
musste ich ihnen lernen aber inzwischen
habe ich ihn verlernt weil ich nicht das
ganze jahr so etwas tragen
ich trage sonst eher große pullover und
t shirt und deine armbänder
ich werde sie wohl ausziehen müssen das
tut weh fertig
[Musik]
annina ist auch botschafterin der schule
sie bereitet sich auf ihre nächste
mission vor auf einer messe in paris
wird sie interessierten studenten den
lehrplan der ehl erläutern entschuldige
die verspätung hatte einen schönen tag
ja ein langer tag
da ein auftrag wird sein die anderen
studenten aufzuklären die möglicherweise
an der ehl interessiert sind
wir werden heute zwei drei sachen
anschauen die du wissen musst um
auskunft zu geben
wir beginnen mit dem bachelor programm
ich denke du kennst es bereits also ich
weiß mehr oder weniger was in dem
semester plänen steht kannst du mir
diese präsentation später zu senden kann
ich machen wenn du willst
gut dann muss ich mir keine notizen
machen du kannst dann auf dem forum
deine informationen über die schule
aufzählen 1893 gegründet etwas mehr als
2700 eingetragene schüler inbegriffen
diejenigen die ein praktikum machen
februar und september beginnt jeweils
die schule circa 100 14 nationalitäten
auf dem campus zwei drittel englisch ein
drittel französischsprachig also 26
wir haben über 30 komitees du kannst
auch vom schüler leben von den
verschiedenen events bei denen du
mitgemacht hast erzählen ob du an events
teilgenommen hast als mitglied eines
komitees und in der organisation und wir
haben ja ein sehr großes netzwerk von
ehemaligen
[Musik]
um diese einführungswoche zu beenden
gibt es nichts besseres als eine kleine
party
auf dem programm steht die schatzsuche
ein einweihungs ritual dass teamgeist
wecken soll
teambuilding wie sie hier sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich packe meinen koffer vier paris ich
gehe an die messe der großen
handelsschulen und vertrete dot de
wir haben dort einen stand um noch mehr
studenten anzuwerben um den ruf unserer
schule zu stärken und um internationale
präsenz zu zeigen
verdienst du etwas dabei ich erhalte pro
stunde 10 schweizer franken auf meine
essens karte mit der wir essen und
trinken oder schokolade in der boutique
kaufen können
für mich ist das gut so denn ich mache
es auch weil ich die schule mag die ich
gewählt habe
und ein großes glück habt die ehl zu
absolvieren
und weil ich gern meine erfahrung in
teile
[Musik]
paris messe der großen handels und
ingenieurschulen wir beginnen mit diesem
vorbereitungsjahr es gibt köchin und
service workshops wir müssen dann auch
die zimmer der anderen machen arbeit an
der rezeption ein bisschen weinkunde
nach diesen fünf monaten macht ihr ein
erstes praktikum in einem hotel irgendwo
auf der welt ihr werdet also reisen
können findet man dann noch leicht
arbeit ja ziemlich leicht sechs monate
nach dem diplom finden 96 prozent der
diplomierten eine feste anstellung also
sehr viel und was kostet es für die vier
jahre kostet es total 155.000 schweizer
franken
ok
155.000 franken die schweizer sind
privilegiert weil die ehl eine
vereinbarung mit der fachhochschule
westschweiz hat sie zahlen die hälfte
also 76 tausend franken
[Musik]
emma ist im morgengrauen aufgewacht und
geht sicheren schrittes zu ihrem ersten
workshop in den schulküchen guten tag
guten tag ist hier die b klasse e klasse
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie man das anzieht was
hast du denn für eine frisur eine art
donath der mich 20 minuten gekostet hat
ich dachte es wäre obligatorisch denn
auf dem kleinen foto hatte das mädchen
diese frisur
also habe ich auch gemacht wenigstens
hat sie kommt alle hierher um 7 uhr seid
ihr alle bereit genau und das armband
weg knöpfe zu
könntest du mir kurz helfen darf man
keine kette tragen nur keine armbänder
[Gelächter]
für die nächsten tage sollte um 7
bereits sein es ist jetzt sechs nach ist
das eure erste woche in der küche dann
gewöhnt euch daran um 7 uhr bereit zu
sein okay emma und ihre kollegen werden
von a bis z alles herstellen was drei
stunden später in gourmet shop des
campus verkauft wird einem take away
service
[Musik]
bei afrim herrscht ein anderer rhythmus
vor in seinem kleinen loser studio
scheinen die campus doppelzimmer weit
weg mein kleines zuhause hier sind ali
james dean und batman bis ich meinen
ersten picasso aufhängen
jetzt beginnt das letzte semester und
mit ihm kommt das berühmte studenten
business project dass alle schüler
erwartet wir sind ein unternehmen
welches schülergruppen einstellt um
einen neuen wöchiges consulting für ein
projekt zu machen marketing finanzen
portfolio t
wir werden sie ihn wie das abläuft das
spp dass studenten business project ist
die letzte prüfung vor dem bachelor
abschluss bleibt ein motivierendes
interessantes projekt zu finden und es
ebenso gut einzufädeln wie die krawatte
beim krawatten binden habe ich ein
kleines geheimnis
ich öffne die knoten nie so verliere ich
morgens keine zeit
alles ist bereit ich weiß die form
stimmt ich trage gerne anzüge
es ist wie eine art uniform an der
schule trotzdem hat jeder ein bisschen
freiheit in seiner kleiderwahl und kann
seinen eigenen stil einfließen lassen
das finde ich ziemlich cool ich mag
diese art von krawatten keine ahnung wie
man die nennt vielleicht socken
krawatten wie auch immer auch die
manschettenknöpfe finden sehen sehr
elegant und professionell aus auch hier
hat man eine gewisse freiheit in der
wahl der knöpfe und den ich sehr viele
besitzer um geld zu sparen und kaufe ich
sie in china bei aliexpress
[Musik]
wo sieht man sich um 11 uhr gleich da
hinten wo uns die klienten nicht sehen
sie haben die namensschild nicht muss
ich jetzt suchen gehen auf jeden fall
holen sie es ich komme gleich ich muss
zum zimmer rennen der erste bank at work
shop für einen alexandra der heute
morgen nicht wirklich glücklich ist
in diesem tempel des gastgewerbes ist
jede abweichung von den regeln und der
kleiderordnung inakzeptabel wenn man
mehr als 15 minuten zu spät ist wird man
nicht zugelassen und man erhält einen
punkteabzug bei der woche vom 6 ich habe
jetzt schon eine 5 als die chance zu
bestehen deutlich verkleinert sie haben
noch 15 minuten zeit
gestern gab es zwei mit 20 minuten
verspätung
sie mussten den tag abbrechen
unterhielten gleich einem minuspunkt
es gibt keine ausreden ich musste heute
morgen mein handy nachschauen ob es
keine flecken hat auf dem anzug hinten
und vorne
wer hat mir beigebracht ein hemd zu
bügeln das war mein vater vor 34 jahren
das lernt man schnell ich habe nur den
vorderen teil des handys gebügelt den
anzug sowie sony ausziehe alles klar
nehmt eure armbänder ab keine ringe den
kleinen knopf hier oben schließen
schwarze socken okay okay sind alle
anwesend elisa alexandra theo marie wir
sind vollständig der stuhl bleibt hier
das hindert uns nicht schon mit der
arbeit zu beginnen
eine der besonderheiten der schule
besteht darin die schüler in eine reale
situation zu versetzen
morgen kommen 260 schüler der eth
lausanne
sie werden in der aula lernen in den
pausen werden sie hier kaffee und tee
trinken
die süßwaren hier in der mitte rosa
betten und protection die zitrone kommt
morgen unterzucker und vier cocktail
tische hiermit abfalleimern und säcken
alles klar
perfekt hast du so was im hotel seines
vaters auch schon gemacht
nein ich habe nie in den hotels meines
vaters gearbeitet
ich mag es nicht wenn die leute wissen
dass ich der sohn des direktors bilden
es ist anders in einem unabhängigen
hotel zu arbeiten
ich habe einige male geschnuppert
bankett vorbereitungen gemacht
eben dreieck so habt ihr es
konzentriert durch machte einen fächer
neue etappe für achim er wird heute das
thema seine studenten business projekts
erfahren wie hören gleich um welches
thema es in unserem neuen wochen
dauernden projekt gehen wird wir werden
sehen wie es läuft
es ist das letzte projekt de hl das ist
aufregend das ist mein team das ziel im
team ist es verschiedene kompetenzen zu
bündeln um möglichst effizient arbeiten
zu können
in neun wochen werden wir sagen können
ob wir uns noch vertragen
und wie es so geht
ich spüre den druck auf rim und sein
team erfahren in wenigen minuten von
welchem der 39 partnerunternehmen sie
ausgewählt worden sind
eine entscheidende wahl zweieinhalb
monate arbeit ein diplom
sogar eine besondere erwähnung in
aussicht der einsatz ist hoch
[Musik]
die wunderbare welt der arbeit zum
ersten mal reitzig alex daran
ich glaube sie zahlt separat sie zahlen
separat entschuldigung
demenz
man ist ja gut
möchten sie eine quittung nein okay
das dauert ein wenig lange
entschuldigung kein problem meine haare
ja ich musste sie schneiden am samstag
seitlich 7 mm und oben 5 cm maximum
vorher hatte ich oben 15 cm
also musste ich zum friseur ziemlich
mies ein vergnügen die haare fallen zu
sehen ob es ist nur für sechs monate das
geht auf rim und sein team möchten gerne
an der organisation der olympischen
jugendspiele teilnehmen die für 2020 in
lausanne geplant sind aber sie sind
nicht die einzigen ein team jubelt aber
es ist nicht das von april
ja es ist nicht sehr cool aber es wird
schon gut sein auch wenn wir nicht unser
lieblingsthema erhalten haben sind wir
trotzdem zufrieden wir werden unsere
motivation steigern
afrika und seine gruppe haben nur ihre
dritte wahl erhalten
aber sie lassen sich nicht entmutigen
nächstes mal in der hotelfachschule wenn
er sich konzentriert arbeitet er sehr
gut
er lässt sich schnell ablenken und
spielt damit seinen kameraden aber meine
kameraden wollen mit mir spielen
[Musik]
wer waren sie ihre tolle energie sehr
gut aber organisieren sie sich ein
bisschen besser
[Musik]
was für ein spaß 819 funktioniert
tatsächlich
ich weiß man muss es gut machen aber mit
etwas humor ging er es besser
[Musik]
manchmal macht es mich ein wenig traurig
wenn ich zu hause in basel bin denke ich
mein leben in basel werde ich vermissen
wenn ich mit der schule fertig bin werde
ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr nach hause
zurückkommen
[Musik]
siehst du eine andere option wir haben
bis jetzt keine gesehen
ja wir haben noch einiges zu erledigen
wir werden sehen wie wir das machen ich
muss los in einer dreiviertelstunde
[Musik]